when you host somebody's luncheon for
them
and you host a team's luncheon for them
a kickoff luncheon for them right
and the season doesn't go as expected
sometimes an an owner can blame it on
the host
or at least the host or at least the
host is genuinely concerned about it
i hosted this man's 2015 kickoff
luncheon
they were fresh off of a conference
championship game appearance they went
eight and eight
yeah so i could not be more thrilled
that this gentleman
would like to doesn't mind calling into
this show after his team just went to
nine and four
with a big win in vegas hitting the
point 44 times in las vegas nevada
he is the owner of the indianapolis
colts jim irsay here on the rich housing
show how are you
jim hey rich what's going on
i'm loving having here how's everything
in your world
oh everything's good you know we love to
have you for that luncheon and
yeah good friend chris berman kind of
being a little bit more quiet in the
back landscape
now you know you're the voice of the nfl
that we all love
love and respect and and uh i always say
it's it's hard
find me one person that doesn't love
rich eyes and i
you know i still haven't had someone
come up to me to find one so
so we certainly appreciate all you do uh
for the nfl and
and and uh all the the the fun things
you bring to the table
on all your interviews man thanks jim it
means the world as you know and i say it
to any member of the nfl that um
you know i do take it as a a uh a
privilege to do this job
uh certainly for our network that's my
gosh that started
17 years ago in our 18th season of nfl
network
and now um your team uh let's talk a
little bit of ball right here
if you don't mind uh before we turn to a
couple of things
off the field including kicking the
stigma which is i know something near
and dear
to your heart and your organizations
your team is at nine and four
right now uh jim how how do you
look at this team compared to other
teams that you've seen in this position
before what do you think
well it's really exciting rich i
i i tell you it's always tough with the
monday uh interviews so when you have
after games you never know
how the game's going to go right so
y'all gotta have to step up or lip and
and be ready to to come on but but i i
tell you
this team has been so impressive
um you know really to go
four foreign one in a playoff atmosphere
um over the last five weeks and it
really has been that i mean when we
beat the raiders yesterday they knew
what was on the line
as we did almost a playoff game
um right there at what was at stake and
and uh you know both games with with
tennessee were
were huge battles and we split but
beating green bay and
houston they knew what was on the line
they had a chance to run the table and
jump back into this thing and and uh
they fought so
gallantly and and uh um
you know as maradona said we had the
hand of god come in on
on at the end of the goal line and knock
that ball out somehow and uh
um recover it you don't win
many like that but uh it's been so
exciting and i
i think there's so many stories that go
around it but
um uh as far as the the changes and
everything i
i think obviously philip rivers um
has been that that that great leader
that that you can't say enough
about um the professional the competitor
uh the selfless player that he is how
the guys
rally around them young and old and um
he's just a special guy and um
uh he's meant a lot uh to us this season
and he's playing hurt right now there's
no doubt about that uh he doesn't like
talking about it but we in the media do
um and with his age and injury
and already word that he's got a
coaching gig waiting for him at the
uh prep level uh in alabama do you think
this
is phillips one and only year with the
colts or are you already talking about
maybe looking over the steering wheel
at all jim well i i'll i'll say this
i mean there's no guarantee there's
going to be any surgery in the offseason
at this point it's something that
um is being evaluated uh um it's not a
definite
um but but he's he's such a tough guy
i don't know how you play uh six days
after an acl
surgery on your knee but uh phillip did
and
and with the toe everyone knows how
tough that
is um for a quarterback uh
driving the ball and that sort of thing
um
uh and really i i
i could see us um
lined up the same way you never know for
sure but
uh with with phillip and jacoby uh
as a one-two punch i you have to give a
lot of credit to jacoby
because he's been such a team player and
he's come in and made some big plays
on some special plays uh in the red zone
and short yardage and different things
that you know i could see us
uh rolling it one more time that
direction
it just it just depends i know that
chris ballard and
uh frank and i just have to talk at the
end of the season
sit down and see where we're at there
but um
but we're really excited the way it's
going now and we're really
an ascending team i i don't know if we
could have won that raider game in
september
um i i i think we are still trying to
figure out who we were
and trying to figure out exactly who is
going to settle into certain roles
uh for our football team but when you
have athletes uh
like quentin nelson popping out at left
tackle
and nahim heims doing the things he does
in between uh gymnastic flips of the end
zone
yes and kenny moore who just um
really uh just uh all pro type of play
uh coming from him and and um
so there's just a really lot of great
news including young guys like
pittman and and taylor at running back
and
and uh we're just really excited though
the way we're playing right now and
you know 2021 isn't that far away
so um uh we'll see what happens in the
off season yeah you're referring to
kenny moore's odell
like interception right in front of
darren waller that was a crucial play in
the uh win for the colts
uh in vegas i've got jim irsay the the
colts owner and ceo here on the rich
eisen show when was the last time you
spoke to andrew luck sir when was that
you know it's it's been a couple months
um
uh really um uh
we've had contact within the
organization
uh frank as frank gregg's talked to him
i know
t y talks to him anthony castanzo um
so um you know he he knows
that our door is always open
um and really it stands that way
as an alumni player who we have so much
respect for
for what he's done for the franchise i
mean this guy
was special he came in and and
you know things like the kansas city
playoff game and we were down 28 points
and
uh one of the great playoff wins in
history um
and uh so so we just
we have great affection for him and um
we're we just wanted to be uh happy rich
we want him to have a fulfilling life
um and do what what you know he really
wants to do because this game is very
demanding
and you have to be all in it's not a
game you can play
um if you're not all in
and i think um he made a courageous
decision and decided well
i think um my direction needs to be
apart from this game going forward and
as shocking as it was um to all of us
including me
um we respected it no doubt and uh
you know as we were talking just moments
ago about looking over the steering
wheel at 2021 at the quarterback
position
do you think it would even be worth
making a run an andrew luck or you think
that that
that's just not even worth the ask well
i think we have to make a run at him i i
think he knows
that um uh we would always
welcome him back with open arms it's
just
that um we respect his decision
and we we don't want to um
you know confuse the situation by
constantly asking a question that he
knows
is there and um uh you know he's retired
he knows what we think about him
um i know that that frank reich and
chris balot's had long conversations
um uh on where we stand and and
and you know sure we'd welcome him back
if he came back but i
i don't think that's realistic i i know
his dad well oliver
and his uncle will who's been his agent
as um
mom's brother who's a great guy and um
and so so really it's one of those
situations
where um again you go intuitively
where you think um you try to
figure out the answer more from an
intuitive nature and i just don't think
um that's in the cards for him to come
back but
but only he can decide that i i mean
only he knows and
he knows we'd welcome him back with open
arms if he did
but um uh as you know we can't as a
franchise
um wait for that to happen i i think
chris and frank and i have been
very um uh disciplined in our thinking
and saying
look at you know he's retired and we
have to operate as such and
and um there you know there's no time to
be
daydreaming on what ifs um uh
if it happens that that's that's great
but um
i just don't i just don't see that in
the cards but anything is possible
indianapolis colts owner and ceo jim is
a few more minutes left with with uh
with jim here on the rich eisen show you
mentioned chris and frank
uh several times and why not hell of a
team that you have
uh with your general manager and chris
ballard who's yoked he's definitely
yoked
uh that's one one aspect about him that
i uh i always notice whenever i'm around
chris and also with the
with uh with frank reich you're your
head coach and i was talking moments ago
about
teams that are are are feeling maybe
bleak right now
not really enjoying the position that
they're in and how you never know
you just never know i'm wondering do you
ever spend time thinking
at any point in time uh and i'm about to
ask you uh
about that moment when josh mcdaniels
told you i'm not coming
and you might have sat there thinking
what now and you look at your coach and
what a
what a gem you have jim did you ever
think about
the way sometimes the football gods
sometimes swing things in your favor
like that you know all the time i
i tell you i i've seen it for a half a
century how
things develop and and and um
you know you just um you think they're
not developing
you know for the right reason or they're
developing against you
when in fact um something greater is
is being um really
drawn together to be presented to you uh
later
and you have to be ready to to seek that
opportunity
you know really being a champion is one
thing it's overcoming adversity
it's the mindset and everyone likes to
talk about adversity
but unfortunately words really don't do
justice
um to what adversity really means at
some times a level it can come to you um
such a competitive environment of cnfl
and um
uh look at you know you just have to
be ready i i i know um
with um uh getting peyton manning i i
mean
jake plummer um had a
come back uh from a two two-score
down situation with uh three or four
minutes left in the game and with
less than 10 seconds um flopped us from
two to one
which allowed us to get peyton uh in 98.
um so you just never know
what what's gonna um twist that way
and and and you always try to um be
ready for the future i remember
uh when i traded chris chandler
with tampa and they said you could have
a uh a two this year or one next year
and i said i'll take a one next year
which was 92
and that ended up giving us the first
two picks in the draft
one and two uh in 92 which is
um you know only the first time really
in modern football history so
uh so you just you try to be ready and
um and when you get dealt a tough hand
um that's really um that's when you have
to be a leader that's when you have to
have that determination that you will
conquer
anything in front of you all right so
let's talk jim irsay
uh about um conquering uh what's in
front of you
maybe being dealt a bad hand and karma
i'm talking about kicking the stigma
what's this about and how people can go
to colts.com to find out all about it
i'll give you the floor jim well it's
something rich that's really
um to me to to my family my daughters
um in in terms of really
addressing um the mental health
stigma problem that exists uh in this
country and i know
um uh ted leonis was on talking to wolf
blitzer about it a few weeks ago
and in this covet environment it is
really really prevalent i mean this is a
all hands on deck a crisis type of
situation
and really the stigma that's attacked
you know tests with mental illnesses um
kill people it literally kills people
and destroys families because
imagine chuck pagano when he
had the cancer diagnosis if he was
uh afraid of shame or worried about
some retribution from somewhere if he
went to chemo
uh therapy to get well i mean that's
what people with mental illnesses face
that that they don't want to come out
and be attached with that stigma
they don't want to be called crazy they
don't want to be called unemployable
they don't want to be pursued by by a
bureaucracy
um that they're they're a wrongdoer in
society or something
and and it's killing people and and we
have to
it's such a major situation in this
country
that we change the way that we approach
mental health because people say with a
mental illness well it's kind of like a
disease
it's not like a disease it is a disease
you don't choose it
and you can't use your own will just to
overcome it and beat it
i i mean you can't look at cancer and
say well i have pancreatic cancer
i have the will because i'm so tough i'm
just gonna beat it
it doesn't work that way and and it
needs tremendous amount of support
from a lot of people and we're really
trying to get that message out i talked
with my friends at rem and mike mills
and i've been nice
friends over 30 years and and we're
using the song everybody hurts
which um all the guys in the band were
gung-ho on on using it
uh for the commercial and um so we're
really excited about it and we're
looking to
to save some lives uh you know we've had
owners in this league lose
um children um family members
through suicide and and other many
different
avenues of mental illnesses and
we really want to change that uh in this
country going forward
and just go find uh the kicking the
stigma page on colts.com for all the
information that you can do again
indiana loses one person by suicide
every eight hours
and it is only getting worse in this in
this pandemic that
uh i i gotta tell you just flipping it
back to football for a quick second here
jim the fact that we're sitting here
getting ready to complete week 14 um to
use the the gruden phrase knock on wood
if you're with me i mean we're
we're we're we're a few weeks away here
is there is there a plan to bubble up
maybe are you guys talking uh and uh and
ladies in the nfl talking is everyone
talking together about
maybe bubbling up for the playoffs in
january where the players go to a hotel
say uh in downtown indianapolis and
that's the way that they
they they live until it's time to go to
the super bowl if you're so fortunate
is that being discussed well you know we
have an owner's
meeting on wednesday um
zoom wise and uh i i really think
rich it's been a tremendous tremendous
accomplishment
um as an industry to be able to go
forward and and having played these
games our trainers our coaches
our players so many people have worked
so hard
um to be able to get to this point and
i think in going forward um
i i i could see more precautions
being brought in and we've even
heightened those
as of late um i i don't see
a bubble situation where we would end up
at one part of the country
right and really play out of one stadium
uh or anything like that but but i think
our diligence is being raised
and and we know um every single day
we have to work hard to um
overcome these obstacles because um
right now um obviously in the country
uh the covet situation the pandemic is
is raging hard and it's not gonna go
away
soon the vaccine is is here almost
but that's gonna take some time so it's
not going to
prevent this year's super bowl in this
end of the
season in the playoffs to be protected
from a vaccine
to the rescue so so we're ready
to do everything we can and we literally
talk day-to-day um and we're really
you know ready to call an audible if we
have to um
and and we take it a day at a time to
see how we can
continue to be successful um but i think
it's a great story and it's been
tremendous for the country
and um for the economic outlook in
general
um to be able to play these games um
and uh it's it's something we're going
to keep working hard um to try to finish
off
with the super bowl in tampa all right
well uh i appreciate the time jim we had
jed york on a couple weeks ago he said
some members in the nfl some owners had
issues
realizing they were on mute during these
zoom so be careful
um just make sure you know you know what
i mean just be careful
well it's it's pretty funny you know you
you you all of a sudden you
you see your fellow owner and he's
handling around his house somewhere
you know the uh you know i'll keep those
stories private but
but uh you get a good laugh now and
again i've seen some good outfits that's
for sure
um but you know hey humor is the bridge
to sanity so we gotta
keep laughing working hard and be
prayerful and spiritual as we move
through this thing because you know
i i mean hey rich we're not human beings
having a spiritual experience we're
spiritual beings having a human
experience right and
different so so we're we're going to
find a way and
and uh we're going to keep working
towards it but uh
you know certainly appreciate the time
and all that thank you
january coming up well i'll be there on
nfl network every single uh
weekday or a weekend day that there's a
there's a game and i'll be there as best
i can
to make sure that the at least the ship
with mooch and erv and kurt are right as
best we can and um congrats on that win
in vegas
and uh good luck to your team moving
forward i appreciate the time as always
thanks so much man you too happy
holidays you too that's jim irsay
ceo owner indianapolis colts
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here